okay this is a response from a viewer
who was watching the third step of my
Rubik's Cube tutorial which shows how to
place middle edge pieces if I understood
him correctly he had a cube very similar
to this one as you could see he had
already placed the green orange edge
piece in between the green and orange
centers and he had already placed the
blue red edge piece in between the blue
and red centers however when he went to
go place the remaining two edges he
noticed that there were no pieces in the
top layer in these four positions which
did not have any yellow in them they all
had yellow that's because the green red
piece and the blue orange edge piece
were already in the second layer however
they had been switched so the blue
orange piece was in between the red and
green centers and the green red piece
was in between the orange and blue
centers so this is very similar to the
situation demonstrated in my third step
where that red blue piece was flipped
however it's slightly more involved and
I felt it was a good situation to post a
video for since other viewers might
experience a similar situation what you
want to do is first separate either of
the incorrectly placed edges from the
corner piece that they are next to so we
can start with either this piece or we
could start with this piece it doesn't
matter as long as you work with them one
at a time you want to fix them one at a
time so let's start with this piece here
what we're going to do is basically put
them on the right side here you can also
put them on the left but I like to put
it on the right so I'm going to put it
on the right and then we're going to
perform a move similar to the one in the
second step so I'm going to turn the
right face clockwise the top face
clockwise and the right face
counterclockwise so let me do that one
more time I'm going to turn the right
face clockwise or up the top face
clockwise and the right face
counterclockwise now what that has done
is it lifted those two pieces from here
to over here now to separate this orange
blue white piece from this incorrectly
placed red green piece we're going to
place this corner piece down like we did
in the second step so we want to match
up this blue color diagonally with its
Center now the white is facing the left
side so we do the move that corresponds
with the left side which is left up or
counterclockwise top towards us
or counterclockwise so now we should see
that white line and then we bring the
left side back down now you'll see that
this blue white orange corner piece has
been separated from that red green edge
piece now what we're going to do is
place this red green edge piece where it
needs to go over here as you'll notice
the blue orange edge piece is there so
we're going to kick it out when we do
that so in order to place it you match
it first with its center color which it
already is matched but if it wasn't what
we're going to do is match this color on
the side which is red with its center
color which is also red now you hold
that Center and you see where this piece
needs to be placed which is over here so
if it needs to go to the right we're
going to hold the center and turn it
away from where it needs to go which is
to the left we then look at the color on
top which is green and we lift the green
side while still holding that red Center
that's very important so we lift the
green side up or right clockwise then we
turn the top face clockwise or towards
us and then we bring the right face
counterclockwise or back down and what
that has done is it lifted these two
pieces now the red green white sent
corner with the orange blue edge piece
that is incorrectly placed so now we
want to do is basically place this
corner down by matching it diagonally
with its Center and then we're going to
place it down
since the white is on the left we do
that same move that corresponds to the
left side which is left counterclockwise
or up and as you'll see this red green
white piece is now paired with its green
red edge piece correctly so I brought
the left face counterclockwise or up the
top face is now going to go
counterclockwise or towards you you
should see a white line and then you
bring the left face back down or
clockwise so now this red green piece is
now placed correctly in between the red
and green centers so now if we look on
top we'll see that we now have that that
blue orange edge piece in the top so now
we do is we now we're going to place
this piece down
over here in between the orange and blue
centers so we first match it up with its
center color which it already is matched
but again if it wasn't we're going to
twist the top until this color on the
side which is orange is matched with its
center color which is also orange we see
that it needs to go in between the
orange and blue centers so we hold the
orange center turn it away from blue
side by twisting the top then we look at
the color on top which is blue while
still holding the iron center we turn
the right face which is blue we turn the
right face clockwise or up then we twist
the top face clockwise and then we bring
the right face back down or counter
clockwise now we'll see that we lifted
up that corner piece which is now over
here to place it back down we're going
to twist the top again to match up the
blue color with its center diagonally
now you'll see that that white color is
on the left side again so we're going to
do the move that corresponds with the
left side left counter clockwise or up
and now you'll see that this blue white
orange piece is paired with its blue
orange edge piece correctly so I brought
the left face counterclockwise or up we
then bring the top face counterclockwise
or towards us so that now we have again
a white line and then we bring the left
face back down now if you did all the
moves correctly you'll notice that the
orange blue edge piece is in between the
orange and blue centers and the red
green piece is now in is now properly
placed in between the red and green
centers so now you should have a
complete bottom two layers so I hope
that that video proved useful if you had
a situation that was very similar to
what the other viewer had any questions
just send me straight on YouTube